en deuxième jour de guerre en ukraine
les russes se concentrent désormais dans
l'est sur la région du donbass région
parti tenu depuis 2014 par des
séparatistes pro russes mais les
loyalistes sur place se mobilisent et
résiste jules boiteau
traverser la rivière est devenu un
véritable parcours du combattant le seul
pont pour accéder à beaubourg yddish
dans la région du dombass a été détruit
ici pas de combat en ce moment mais les
détonations d'artillerie rappelle chaque
jour aux habitants la menace venue du
front voisins c'est un jeune danny watts
un peu plus loin ce to doc le bon tiens
encore mais peut-être plus pour très
longtemps
dans cette région rurale de l'est de
l'ukraine des blocs de pierre barrent
les routes pour ralentir la progression
des chars russes les soldats
d'ukrainiens préparent leur défense et
se tiennent très déterminé main retrouvé
as byatt au risque le toit du monastère
a subi les dommages de récentes
explosions beaucoup de combattants
d'ukrainiens convergent dans ce moment
vers cette petite ville occupée par les
russes lorsque le conflit a éclaté en
mais c'est normal c'est annick
jakobowicz
radio notamment
les menus
redoutant d'être pris en tenaille les
autorités ukrainiennes dodo nièce qui
est de louhansk ont demandé l'évacuation
des civils akram à torse près de 3000
habitants fuient vers l'ouest ces
derniers jours